i'm very
curious about a theory probably
hypothesis
you once mentioned about dog
consciousness being enhanced by
association with us
question mark totally and i must say i
share
credit for that hypothesis with our dog
luckily she does not ask for authorship
on such things no she's very generous
with respect to
authorship although she's going to be
mad to find out that she's been
diagnosed as a golden retriever
right and when that dog gets mad i've
actually never seen it right it doesn't
happen
it doesn't get mad she gets even no
um okay so the question is
why would i say such a thing about it
i'm just curious i'm curious about a
hypothesis you want to mention about dog
consciousness being enhanced by
association with us
okay so you gotta step into uh heather
and
my toolkit on consciousness which starts
from the premise
that consciousness is most fundamentally
about the so-called inter-subjective
space that is to say
the reason that you would evolve
something as clumsy as
consciousness is because it's the only
way to accomplish the trick
of exchanging abstract ideas between two
individuals you have to basically have
an agreement on what you've said
right so that you you know what it is
that you're processing
that means that um basically there has
to be
a shared space and the point is that
shared space
is inherently about language right
language is the tool that we use to
access the shared space to hand over an
idea to get it parallel processed which
is the reason for consciousness
once you have that consciousness you can
do it in your own mind you can
debate between two possibilities just as
you would between two people
but the point is the more linguistic you
are
the more rendered that shared
space is and the weird thing is that
dogs are pretty much second right you
can make an argument for
certain birds that they can get a large
vocabulary
and i've in fact heard some stories even
last week we heard a story
about a bird that appeared to be able to
put together uh
disjunct words to make new concepts i'd
love to see that demonstrated but anyway
a parrot one of a couple of families in
which you might expect such
such things corbett's would be another
pros raven's js
but the point is dogs are
weirdly asymmetrical language-wise they
can only say a few words
mostly loudly yes um i can't say any
words
but they can understand a great uh many
words they can have a large vocabulary
of things that they actually do
they have no productive language but
they have receptive language right
what's more
if you look at our shared consciousness
model it really isn't about language
itself
it is about understanding what the other
person is thinking which language is by
far the most efficient way to do that
and dogs are pretty good at
understanding what we're saying to them
if we're consistent about it but dogs
are really good at figuring out what
we're thinking from other cues too
you know as hunting partners for example
the dog intuits what it is that
the hunter that they are partnered with
wants them to do to facilitate
the hunt because they understand the
hunter because they've done it a bunch
of times and they get used to the
pattern the way
people on a soccer field would get used
to what their teammates are going to do
and they would intuit it without anybody
having to say anything
so the point is it is the partnership
between people
and dogs that has clearly made dogs more
conscious than
their wild counterparts and i would
argue
more conscious than even our closest
relatives
in many cases so dogs are a special case
because they've hung out with us for so
long and i
the thing about dogs that you don't
necessarily
intuit is their history of domestication
is longer than any other critters
it's longer and more intense because it
doesn't have anything to do with farming
it had to do with hunting
and because it had to do with hunting it
goes back some 30 000 years whereas
every other
human partnership with an animal it just
goes back less than 10.
so anyway dogs are special they've been
hanging out with us for a long time and
they have some idea what we're thinking
at this point which is the basic answer
to your question
you